John Ratcliffe joins us tonight with his
reaction to what is happening in that
country tonight mraco thank you so much
for coming on so hey it's hard to have
perspective on this for most people
including me when you see these videos
how significant how serious are these
protests potentially do you think
well we've never seen protests like this
uh in over 30 years in China and it
really will force the Chinese government
to change their governance model ever
since Tiananmen Square Tucker what the
Chinese Communist party has done he said
we're not going to let that happen again
we're going to engage in the largest
massive surveillance state in the
history of the world against our own
citizens and if we get even a whiff of
discontent we're going to stamp it out
and they've been successful in doing
that this is the first time in 33 years
that we've now seen Nationwide protests
and it's not just a the problem or the
challenge for Xi Jinping in the Chinese
Communist party is it's moved from just
a one-issue covet issue to now a call
for his removal and for regime change so
I don't think anyone knows exactly how
this will play out but it's very serious
and very clearly the Chinese Communist
party is going to have to adopt a
different governance model going forward
in light of what's happening there I I
don't think a day has passed in the last
two years where the rest of us haven't
gotten a lecture about quote democracy
from the Biden Administration given
their commitment to democracy how can
they not have a position on this
well the president's statement today was
uh let's just be nice it was uh it was
late slow week and cowardly that's about
the kindest thing you can say I mean
this is the same president who uh had an
opportunity to confront the Chinese
president after three years and a
million Americans were killed by a virus
that originated in China and he didn't
do it so so as disheartening as it is
it's not surprising
um and you know I thought you and Laura
really outlined you know what's happened
here the Silence from the left is
deafening you know as dni I saw this
type of uh you know Intelligence on a
daily basis about how brutal the Chinese
Communist Party could be
um but on the left on the left what
we've seen is uh you know some are
silent because of greed that's your
Hollywood crowd your Wall Street crowd
your NBA groups and organizations that
want access to 1.4 billion Chinese and
no matter what they do uh it's not going
to be enough to turn them away from that
but the other as Laura said are the
group just complicit that's your
Washington politicians your blue State
Governors your Dr Anthony fauci's your
teachers union president Randy
Weingarten these are the people who
can't condemn the Chinese Communist
party because to do so would be to
condemn condemn themselves they are the
group that has praised and protected and
defended and in some cases emulated the
same lockdown measures that the Chinese
Communist party is engaged in right now
and to condemn the Chinese Communist
Party would be to condemn themselves
into the amid the American people that
they've been lying for three years and
that they were wrong and I don't think
we're going to see that
anyone who's awake at all can see
exactly what's going on here and I think
they're playing with fire you can't you
can't keep lying to this uh level
forever I would say John Radcliffe great
to see you tonight thank you so much you
too thanks Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight